[موسيقى
] أشعر بالأمل في
أن نتمكن من تقديم الابتكار للمرضى
بحيث تستمر
سنوات إلى شهور حتى يتمكن المرضى
من الاستفادة من
الأفكار والابتكارات الذكية.
تاريخ إيفا
فارمر وعلى الرغم من أنها
تأسست في عام 1997 إلا
أنها شركة تعتمد
على واحدة من أكبر وأقدم شركة
في مصر أه تمتد لأكثر من مائة
عام ،
لذا أخبرني عن التحول إلى
مزارع شرير
على خلفية شركة  كان
مجرد جزء مهم من إنشاء
المستحضرات الصيدلانية
في البلد الذي أنت محق تمامًا في
أن شركتنا تعمل
في مجال الرعاية الصحية في الأدوية لأكثر من 100
عام ، بدأنا في عام 1917
مع شركة توزيع بسيطة بحلول عام
أه كان هناك
شركة مرخصة في مصر هي الأولى
في مصر وهي من أوائل الشركات في القارة الأفريقية
في تصنيع المنتجات الصيدلانية الجاهزة
وللأسف تم تأميمنا في
الستينيات
لذلك كان علينا إعادة تجديد  ر ولكن اليوم
نحن أحد كبار المطورين
المُصنِّعين
للأدوية في
شمال إفريقيا ،
أعني أنه ليس فقط الفضاء الصيدلاني
هو الذي يحاول إيجاد
حلول
محلية لأه تعلم أن العرض الذي
ستستورده عادةً ، هل تعتقد أن هذا
هو
سيكون اتجاهًا مهمًا
للغاية سيخرج من
الوباء
كما تعلم أننا بدأنا العمل على
هذا لتوطين تصنيع
المكونات الصيدلانية النشطة التي صممناها
بالفعل
مفاعلات من مصادر مبنية مرخصة
ومصنعة لمكونات صيدلانية نشطة
لأحد منتجاتنا الرئيسية  المنتجات
التي تعتبر
منتجًا لك تعرف المنتج الرئيسي
المضاد للفيروسات
لـ uh covert 19 rendezvir ،
هذا أحد الأمثلة حيث كان علينا
أن
ننظر داخليًا لتوطين ولكننا
نعمل مع شركاء مختلفين
للتأكد من أنه يمكننا أن نكون
أنفسنا-  كافية داخل مدينتنا
وبلدنا ونأمل أن تكون داخل القارة ، نعم ،
أعني أننا نتحدث عن
شركة
ال  في حول أنك تعرف أكثر من 100 عام ،
لذا من الواضح أن لديك
القدرات التي لديك الدراية الفنية
ولكن رد الفعل على هذا الوباء عليك
القيام به بسرعة كبيرة وعليك اتخاذ
قرارات كبيرة جدًا ، نعم بالتأكيد
نحن مجموعة  لدينا الكثير من التاريخ
ولدينا قدرات مختلفة ولكن آه
لقد أصبحنا شركة مختلفة
تمامًا فقط للرد على الطمع 19.
معظم المنتجات التي ذكرتها
هي منتجات لم نمتلكها
والتي تم تطويرها خصيصًا استجابة
للعلاج الطبي  التي كانت مطلوبة من
أجل الطمع 19.
[الموسيقى]
ولكن ما هي خطة اللعبة بالنسبة لك
في المستقبل
حيث ترى أنفسنا نحن موجودون
في صناعة ذات اقتصاديات ضخمة ،
لذا يتعين علينا تحقيق الحجم حتى نتمكن
من الابتكار
لنكون قادرين  لكي ننمو وأن نكون قادرين على
مساعدة المزيد من المرضى بكفاءة أكبر
في أجزاء مختلفة من العالم ، لذلك
نحن نحاول تحقيق هذه المهارة
لدينا خطة طموحة
لمحاولة أن نصبح أحد أفضل 20
مرضًا بحلول عام 2029 اليوم
نحن بالتأكيد على  e من
الشركات الرائدة في إفريقيا
ولكن مرة أخرى ، فإن إفريقيا
ككل ربما تكون ثلاثة بالمائة من سوق الأدوية العالمي ،
لذا فإن كونك أحد أفضل
اللاعبين على
مستوى العالم مع استمرار وجودك في
إفريقيا
هو هدف نريد أن نكون أحد
أفضل 20 شركة  تعني في الأساس
أننا بحاجة إلى أن يكون حجمنا 12 ضعفًا في
السنوات القليلة
التي تسبق عام 2029